جدا على العمل المشترك في هذا الاطار
شكرا انا
السياسيا لانها تقدم المساعده الى روسيا
هل ستفرض الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بعد
العقوبات على الصين بالاضافه الى ذلك هل
هناك اي خطوات متخذه في ذلك
ايضا
وتنشيط هذه المحطات في ايران ايضا كيف
ستنعكس هذه كيف سينعكس هذا الملف ايضا على
الملف اتفاق الملف النووي
وايضا هناك بعض الاطراف التي تقدم
المساعدات الى روسيا
ما هو رايكم ذلك بالنسبه الى الصين
وبالنسبه الى روسيا ذكرنا سابقا
وزملائي في الاداره الامريكيه ذكر ذلك
مجددا نحن نراقب
بقلق هذه المساعدات الصينيه الى روسيا
وخصوصا في اطار الاسلحه نحن في واشنطن ان
نراقب هذا الملف
وكان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اتذكر ذلك
لقد تحدث الى الرئيس الصيني في تلك الاونه
وتحدث ايضا ان هذا الملف سيكون ملف
مغاير لسياسات المشتركه بين اولياء
المشتركه بين
الامريكيه والصين هذا
هذه المساعدات
تتطلب عقوبات لا لا استطيع الان ان اتحدث
اليكم بلغه حاسمه لان المباحثات مستمره
المتابعات مستمره
شاركنا هذه المخاوف مع المسؤولين الصينيين
وربما يتطلب هذا الامر بعض العقوبات ولكن
الصين الان فهمت هذه المخاطر
وفي حال استمرارهم لتقديم المساعدات
العسكريه الى روسيا فسيتطلب الملف الان
بعض العقوبات التي بامكاننا ان نفرضها على
الصين لذلك الان الصين فهمت هذا الامر
اتخاذ بعض الخطوات اللازمه
لاتخاذ تدميرنا ايضا في هذا الامر
وبالتالي
اعتقد ان السن الان
تتوقف ربما عن تقديم الدعم بالنسبه الى
الطاقه الذريه وبالنسبه الى ملف الطاقه
الذريه الان نستمر ايضا بالمباحثات مع مع
الحلفاء الاوروبيين نبحث عن الكثير من
المعلومات ونجمع المعلومات هذا الموضوع
للغايه ولا يمكن الحديث عنه في بشكل دقيق
الان
بدايه الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه كانت
تركيا لديها مواقف
ثابته
ونحن ندعم وحده الاراضي الاوكرانيه
لا نعترف
بالاستفتاء من جانب واحد والغير قانوني
وايضا ضم الاراضي بشكل غير قانوني الى
روسيا
مواقف تركيا واضحه جدا حيث انها تنفذ ايضا
اتفاقيات بشكل واقعي وبشكلا
حساس للغايه ايضا نستمر بالمباحثات بين
الجانب الروسي وبين الجانب الاوكراني بشكل
منفصل
ولن نسمح الى مرور كما اننا لم نسمح الى
مرور اي سفينه عسكريه عبر مياه البحر
الاسود
ولكن تركيا لا تشارك بفرض العقوبات يعني
نحن لا
نشارك بفرض العقوبات من جانبا واحد طبعا
ونحن نوافق على اتخاذ بعض القرارات مع
الامم المتحده مثلا كيف يمكن مواجهه
الارهاب كيف يمكن مثلا مواجهه ايدولوجيه
فاصله بين الدول ولكن من جانب اخر
ان نرى ان العقوبات الاوروبيه وعقوبات
المتحده الامريكيه
لا يمكن ان تكون عبر تركيا يعني تركيا لن
تسمح لي ان تكون هذه العقوبات او ان تركيا
تكون جزءا من هذه العقوبات او الزر
الخزانه والماليه الامريكي كان هنا في
تركيا
زار تركيا وكان هناك بعض المعلومات
والملفات التي تصل الى تركيا ما انتبه الى
هذه الملفات
طبعا نناقش كل هذه الملفات نرى ان بعض
الملفات بالفعل ضروري اتخاذ تدابير واتخاذ
الاحتياطات الممكنه فبعض المنتجات
الاوروبيه تصل الى تركيا
تصديرها مثلا الى روسيا نتخذ ايضا هذه
التدابير الى عدم تصدير هذه البضائع
والسلع الى روسيا عن طريق تركيا نعم هناك
حجم تبادل تجاري مرتفع ولكن 60% منها كحجم
اتحدث هي
الغاز الطبيعي وايضا بعض مواد الطاقه طبعا
الان
اسعار الغاز الطبيعي تضاعفت بثلاث اضعاف
تقريبا التي ندفعها الى روسيا هناك بعض
المواد الغذائيه ايضا التي نصدرها الى
روسيا ولكن هي ليست
المواد الاوروبيه او الامريكيه يعني نحن
كما ذكرنا اننا نسعى الى تكون جزءا من هذه
العقوبات ونحن
الصادقين
هذه مع هذه التي فاذا كان هناك اي وثائق
تدل على ذلك الاتحاد الاوروبي بامكانها ان
تقدمه لنا واذا كان هناك اي خلل في ذلك او
عدم التزام في ذلك نتخذ كل التدابير
اللازمه شكرا
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اذا تابعنا هذا المؤتمر
الصحفي لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطون
بلينكن ووزير الخارجيه التركي
مولود شاوش اوغلو الذي اكد فيه الجانب
الامريكي طبعا على الدعم المادي والمعنوي
لتركيا بعد الزلزال المدمر الذي ضربها
بالاضافه الى سوريا بالاضافه الى ملفات
اخرى تم التطرق اليها مثل انضمام السويد
وفنلندا الى الناتو وايضا تزويد تركيا
بمقاتلات اف 16
وملفات اخرى نتابع هذه النشره ونبقى في
تركيا حيث وصلت رحله البحث عن ناجحه من
الزلزال زلزال تركي وسوريا الى محطتها
الاخيره وبدات المناطق المنكوبه برفع
الانقاذ وحصر الاضرار فيما لا تزال
السلطات تكافح رواء المنكوبين لكن رغم وقف
عمليات الانقاذ قد تحدث المعجزات لا سيما
بعد ان نجحت الفرق بانقاذ ثلاثه اشخاص في
هاتاي في اليوم الثالث عشر لذلك تتمسك هذه
الفرق بفحص المواقع بدقه التي تتم فيها
ازاله الانقاذ املا في العثور على ناجينا
جدد في الوقت ذاته لا يزال خطر انهيار
المباني قائما فعليا وسط استمرار الهزات
الارتداديه في المناطق المنكوبه لهذا
تواصل السلطات التركيه عمليات اجلاء
السكاني وتقييم حاله المباني ومدى
جائزيتها للسكان
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
ما شاء الله
في تركيا وسوريا تكاد كل من تلك الدولتين
تستفيق على امل الا ويرافقه حزن وفي كل
يوم تمبش فيه فرق لانقاذ ناجن بمعجزه يكون
الواقع امر فالزلزال غيب الكثيرين تحت تلك
الانقاد حيث ارتفعت حصيله وفيات الزلزال
المدمر في تركيا الى واحد واربعين الفا
وعشرين وفاه بحسب بيانات رئاسه اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه وافقى التقرير
فان سته الاف ومئتين واثني عشر هزه
ارتداديه وقعت عقب الزلزال المزدوج في
ولايه كهرمان مرعش وبينما يقوم نحو 20,000
من فرق البحث بالعمل الى جانب الاليات
الثقيله اكدت دراسات تقيم الاضرار التي لم
تكتمل بعد ازاله 105 الاف مبنى لحقت بها
اضرار جسيمه طبعا تسعى اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه لاقامه
الف بيت مسبق التجهيز خلال شهرين اما
حاليا اجمالي الخيام التي اقيمت في مناطق
الزلزال بلغت 250 الفا وستبلغ في وقت قريب
300 الف خيمه فالذين لا يملكون شيئا ضاقت
بهم السبل فوجدوا في تلك الخيام ملجئا اما
الاخرون فينزحون لولايه اخرى حيث قرروا
العيش مع اقاربهم او استئجار منازل ريثما
يعيدون بناء بيوتهم لكنهم يواجهون مشكله
اخرى تتمثل بمحاولات البعض استغلال هذه
الكارثه ورفع ايجارات المساكن بشكل مبالغ
فيه وفي هذا السياق اكدت السلطات التركيه
انها ستتصدى لهذا الامر بحسمه وعدا عن خطر
الهزات الارتداديه المخاوف قائمه خشيه من
زلزال مدمر اخر في السنوات المقبله حيث
وجه رئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام ابتداء
عاجلا الى سكان المدينه للاسراع في اجراء
الكشف اللازم على قوه
وقوه تحمل هذه المباني التي انشات قبل عام
1999 للزلزل في ائمه ان تهدم او يعيدون
تعميرها وفق القواعد التي تمكنها من
مواجهه اي زلزال محتمل في حين اعلنت ولايه
اسطنبول نقلت 52 الف طالب من 93 مدرسه في
انحاء المدينه لدراسه في مدارس اخرى من
اجل هدمها واعاده بناءها او ترمي من بعضها
[موسيقى]
وينضم الينا من اسكندرون جنوب تركيا مراسل
العربيه زيدان زين كلو اهلا بك معنا زيدان
في هذه الساعه الاخباريه يعني ضعنا في
اجواء الصوره من عندك خاصه مع انتهاء
عمليات الانقاذ والبدء بهدم المباني
وجمع الردم طبعا
نعم راويه نحن نعم نعم راويه نحن الان في
ميناء اسكندرون هذا الميناء الذي كان محور
للاحداث في الايام الاولى من الزلزال كما
تشاهدين دمار كبير في هذا
الميناء عشرات الحاويات التي دمرت اضافه
طبعا الى الحاويات او مئات الحاويات التي
تضررت نتيجه الحرائق التي اشتعلت في
الايام الاولى لهذا الزلزال طبعا ميناء
اسكندرون كما ذكرت كان محور الاحداث خلال
ايام الاولى بسبب الحرائق التي لم تتوقف
خلال اول ثلاثه ايام من الزلزال وبالتالي
كان هناك جهود كبيره من السلطات في محاوله
اطفاء الحرائق كما تشاهدون ما تبقى من هذه
الحاويات هنا في هذا الميناء قد
اصبحت اثرا بعد عين اضافه الى دمار حاويات
اخرى لم يصلها لم تصلها الحرائق عفوا
لكنها دمرت بشكل كبير اذا دمار كبير في
ميناء اسكندرون لكن السلطات يعني قبل قليل
عندما كنا نجول قرب هذا الميناء شاهدنا
عشرات الاليات التي تحاول ابعاد هذا
الركام لتسهيل حركه او التسهيل عوده
الحياه الطبيعيه والعمل في هذا الميناء
الى ما كان عليه قبل الزلزال كما ذكرت
راويه بالعوده الى موضوع رفع الانقاض لا
شك ان اعمال البحث والانقاذ قد انتهت بشكل
تقريبا شبه كامل في عشر ولايات منكوبه
حاليا الجهود تتركز على توفير مساكن مؤقته
كنا يوم امس في ولايه غازي عنتاب تحديدا
في مدينه اصلاحيه نستطيع القول ان اعمال
تجهيز المساكن مسبقه الصنع والكرفانات قد
وصلت الى ما نسبته تقريبا 40% في محاوله
وسباق مع الزمن لتجهيز هذه المساكن هناك
في اصلاحيه في غازي عنتاب في اقرب وقت بال
كما ذكرتم حركه النزوح مستمره من هذه
الولايات الى ولايه اكثر امنا مع اطلاق
الحكومه التركيه قبل يومين برنامج بيتك
بيتي في محاوله
توفير ايضا مساكن اضافيه حيث تشمل هذه
المبادره تقديم اصحاب كل من يملك منزلين
هذا الشخص الذي يملك منزلين بامكانه
التبرع اما بشكل مجاني
لعائله من الجنوب الولايات المنكوبه او
الحصول على اجار رمزي تتكفل الحكومه
التركيه بدفعه وبضمانه الحكومه التركيه
بالنسبه لاسطنبول نعم اعمال الكشف او
تقريبا اعمال او فرق البحث
والكشف على المباني
تقوم بعملها بيانات رسميه اكدت ان نسبه او
الطلبات التقدم من المواطنين للكشف عن على
المباني ارتفعت بما نسبته تقريبا 90% بعد
حدوث الزلزال هذه الطلبات تقدم الى
البلديات المحليه هناك في اسطنبول وتقوم
فرق من البلديه بمراجعه الطلب ومن ثم
ارسال فريق الى المبنى للتاكد من سلامته
وموافقته للشروط
الزلازل اذا كما تابعنا يعني حاله من
جهود كبيره من الحكومه التركيه لتوفير
مساكن مؤقته ومحاول بدا بعمليه رفع
الانقاض استعدادا لبدء عمليات اعاده
الاعمار
زيدان يعني باختصار لو سمحت الصوره التي
نشاهدها هي طبعا لميناء اسكندرون حيث
الزلزال شاهدنا العديد من الفيديوهات
الاحتراق هذه الحاويات ولكن سؤالي لك يعني
هل العمل في هذا الميناء متوقف بشكل كامل
وهل من موعد تقريبي لعودته او استئنافه
للعمل ان كان بشكل كلي او جزئي
نعم يعني من خلال ما شاهدناه لا هناك حركه
جزئيه في المينايه نحن وصلنا الى هذه
المنطقه قبل حوالي ساعه رصدنا هناك بعض
الاليات التي تعمل لكن هذه المنطقه التي
نتواجد فيها الان العمل فيها متوقف بشكل
كامل لكن في بقيه مواقع الميناء نعم هناك
حركه ايضا هناك موانئ قريبه يعني اسكندرون
لا تعتمد فقط على هذا الميناء هناك موانئ
قريبه تبعد حوالي 15 كيلو مترا الى 17 كلم
العمل فيها جار على قدم وساق وهناك ايضا
سفينه رست قبل ايام وفي سفينه لايواء
لمتضرري الزلزال فيها شقق فندقيه او غرف
فندقيه لايواء عشرات العائلات المتضرره من
الزلزال ايضا ترسوا في ميناء قريب هنا من
اسكندرون لا نستطيع ان نقول ان العمل توقف
بشكل شبه كامل لكن في المناطق التي تضررت
هنا في زلزال نعم لا توجد اي حركه هنا في
هذا المكان
جزيلا لك اذا من اسكندرون جنوب تركيا
مراسل العربيه زيدان
اعلنت منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله يونيسف
ان 7 ملايين طفل في سوريا وتركيا معرضون
للخطر واوضحت ان حوالي مليونين و500 الف
طفل باتوا في خطر عقب الزلزال في سوريا
وكذلك الامر بالنسبه لاكثر من 4 ملايين
الف في تركيا تحديدا يوسف اوضحت ايضا ان
عائلتها هؤلاء الاطفال تواجه ظروفا صعبه
ناجمه عن الكارثه سيما وانهم دون مساكن
ايوائيه معرضون لمخاطر الاصابه بالكوليرا
وامراض اخرى كما اكدت المنظمه مواصله
تقييم الوضع وتحديد المخاطر المحتمله في
كل من سوريا وتركيا وحول هذا الموضوع ينضم
الينا من اسطنبول الكاتب السياحه في فراس
رضوان اوغلو اهلا بك سيد فراس يعني
اليونيسف تتخوف من
تفشي للاوبئه في سوريا ماذا عن الوضع في
تركيا وما المعلومات المتوفره هل رصدتم اي
مؤشرات
الخيم الاماكن التي يتجمع فيها الاطفال
دون اي مقومات للحياه
وحتى الان يعني لم يتم الاعلان عن اي يعني
مرض او اي افه او اي شيء من هذا الامور
الصحيه لكن وزير الصحه كان تكلم قبل فتره
قريبه جدا على انه وزاره الصحه تاخذ بين
اعتبار المخاوف الصحيه من انتشار او بيئه
في مناطق التي المناطق المدن العشر التي
ضربها الزلزال لذلك انا اظن ان
كما قال ان هناك ايضا يعني لنقل الاستنفار
طبيا في الداخل التركي حتى من الولايات
الاخرى تم استجلام كثير من الممرضين
والاطباء في في هذا الامر لكن حتى الان لم
يتم الاعلان عن اي امر لك ايضا لم يتم
الاعلان عن هل تم اعطاء يعني جرعات اضافيه
دوائيه او من هذا القبيل لم يذكر ذلك لان
بشكل عام ربما النظام الصحي في تركيا
يعتمد على الاطفال منذ يتم لديهم نظام
المتابعه
للقاحات وما شابه ذلك لكن الان حتى الان
اظن يعني الامور يتكلمون على ان لم يحصل
شيء لكن التخوفات موجوده لماذا لان لم يتم
نقل حتى الان كل الذين تضرروا من الزلزال
الى اماكن لنقل صحيه على الاقل للخياميه
ليست صحيحه حتى مراكز الايواء ليست صحيه
بسبب الاقتصاد الذي موجوده فيه لكن اظن
هذا سيحل مع البلديه
الحكومه في هذا الامر الى ذلك الوقت
سننتظر التقارير الطبيه من وزاره الصحه
التركيه
خسروا اهلهم بهذا الزلزال تحديدا بمناطق
الجنوب التركي فعليا كيف يتم التعامل معهم
يعني سمعنا عن ان نرد عن نقلوا الى انقره
هؤلاء الى اي مناطق ينقلون وفق اي اليه
يعني هل اعلنت وزاره الصحه او الوزاره
المختصه كيفيه التعاطي مع هذا الملف
بالنسبه للرضع كما تفضلتي نعم ربما كانت
العمل كان ربما اوضح والخطه كانت واضحه
اكثر بالنسبه لباقي الاطفال يعني حتى الان
انا ما قرات عن خطه واضحه حقيقيه طبعا
هناك اي سيكون اعاده تاهيل هناك سيكون
بالنسبه ايضا لاعاده تاهيلهم في المدارس
هذه نقطه اولى سيكون هناك ما يسمى
بالمرشدين النفسيين لايجاد صيغ لهؤلاء
الاطفال الذين اما تضرروا مباشره من
الزلزال ولم يفقدوا ذويهم او اما انه
تضرروا مباشره من الزلزال وفقد احد ذويه
او كلهم هذا كله سيكون كما قال الوزير
سيكون هذا للمرشدين النفسيين سيكون
المتواجدين بشكل كبير ايضا تم ايجاد صيغه
الهؤلاء الاطفال اذا تم نقله بين مدارس
اخرى كل وسائل النقل التي تقل الى مدرستهم
ستكون مجانيه على حساب الدوله طبعا سيتم
هناك ايضا اضافه مقاعد وصفوف مدارس اخرى
واعاده ربما
توزيع لنقل دورات التعليم يعني صفقات
الذهاب الى المدرسه من الصباح وسيكون هناك
ما بعد الظهر الى المساء يعني
عمل في في هذا السياق اظن
التكلم الوزير حول المتابعه للاطفال مع
ذويهم ايضا في هذا الاسياخ يعني هناك
احتياجات المدرسيه هناك الاحتياجات ايضا
اللباس وما شابه ذلك طبعا المرتبطه في
المدارس هذه كلها اظن ستكون الوزاره
والحكومه بالتكلف لذلك لكن كخطه كما حصل
للاطفال الرضع يعني حتى الان لا يمكن ان
نقول انها خطه واضحه
مساله التعليم شكرا جزيلا لك من اسطنبول
الكاتب او الصحفي فراس رضوان اوغل
[موسيقى]
كنت استيقظ في غرفه دافئه لكنني الان
استيقظ في محطات الوقود وابحث عن حوض
الاستحمام ضاعت فرصنا وذهبت ثقتنا بانفسنا
[موسيقى]
نحن بحاجه الى الكهرباء والماء للاستحمام
الاتصالات غير موجوده ونحن معرضون للخطر
البالغ في الوقت الحالي
اريد تصميم هذه المغسله لتلبيه احتياجات
الناجين من الزلزال والذين يحتاجون الى
مرافق للاستحمام وغسيل الملابس نسعى
جاهديا لتقديم اكبر قدر ممكن من المساعده
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
لقاء صيني روسي مرتقب يقلق امريكا وبكين
تحذر لن نسمح لاحد بالضغط علينا
قصف اوكراني مكثف على دنياك وضواحي بخموت
وروسيا تتهم كييف بارتكاب اباده جماعيه في
بعد استفزازات كوريا الشماليه بالتجارب
الصاروخيه الباليستيه الامم المتحده تحذر
واليابان تندد
اغلاقه معبر طور خم الحدوديه مع افغانستان
بعد اشتباكات عنيفه بين قوات طالبان وحرس
الحدود الباكستاني
اهلا بكم من جديد تزداد وتيره المعارك
فيسك شرق اوكرانيا وسط قصف صاروخين بين
الحين والاخر حيث وقع قتيل واصيب احدى عشر
بعد استهداف الجيش الاوكراني مجددا او ان
استهدف احياء مدينه ومراكز حكوميه في قلب
دنيا في الاثناء افاد مراسل العربيه بان
قوه فاجنر الروسيه تتقدم من عده بلدات الى
مركز مدينه بخموت الاوكرانيه
قبل اكمال عام على الاعمال العسكريه في
اوكرانيا يستانف الجيش الاوكراني قصفه
لمدينه دانيت هذه
احدى الاسواق التي تم قصفها 45 صاروخ
استهدفت مناطق مدنيه حيث
استهدفت صواريخ جراد وفمبير تشيكيه
وبولنديه الصنع مناطق مختلفه من المدينه
هنا هذه السوق فيها اثار احدى القذائف
التي سقطت على هذه المحلات التجاريه
هذا الامر لا يتوقف هنا في كل الاحياء وفي
كل مكان لا يوجد احياء لم تسقط فيها
الغذائف والصواريخ لقد احتدنا على ذلك
وتستمر الاعمال العسكريه بالقصف المتبادل
ما بين الطرفين الاوكراني والروسي وقد
استهدفت الضربات الاوكرانيه عددا من
المباني الحكوميه والمباني السكنيه في
المدينه وبعد هذا القصف اوقف عمده
العمل في شبكه المواصلات المحليه هنا
تحسبا من استمرار القصف الاوكراني الذي
ربما يخلف مزيدا من القتلى ومن الضحايا
وتستمر القذائف والصواريخ بالسقوط على
مناطق مختلفه في قلب المدينه بشكل عشوائي
وهذا موقع اخر وهو مكتبه المدينه
مكتبته دانيت المدنيه موقع اخر فيه محل
تجاريه تضررت اثراء القصف هنا في هذا
الموقع بالذات سقط صاروخ من طراز جراد
لقناتي العربيه والحدث رائد الاغبر دانيت
وانضم الينا من دونيتسكا مراسل العربيه
رائد الاغبر اهلا بك رائد يعني ماذا في
تفاصيل الاستئناف القصف الاوكراني على
مدينه دنيتسكو طبعا قبل ايام معدوده من
اكمال هذه الحرب لعامها الاول
راويه بالفعل يعني ما زالت الاعمال
العسكريه الكبيره والعنيفه مستمره لا
يتوقف القصف المتبادل ما زلنا نسمع منذ
الصباح الباكر ومنذ عده ايام اصوات اطلاق
النار الكثيف وايضا ذوي الانفجارات هنا في
المدينه في قلب المدينه وعلى احياء اطراف
المدينه كما ان مدن اخرى
لا اعلم هل تسمع اصوات الانفجارات
والاطلاق الصواريخ هنا بكثافه يعني يعني
ارتفعت وتيره القصف المتبادل بالفعل راويه
لدرجه كبيره في الايام الاخيره هناك ايضا
حضور وتواجد كبير للجنود المستجدين الروس
الذين يصلون الى مدينه دانياس ثم ينتقلون
الى الجبهات الى الجبهات المختلفه طبعا
الجبهات كلها مشتعله جبهه جنوبيه والجبهه
الشماليه وحتى اطراف
هناك منطقه ليمان وكوبيان استشهد تقدم
للقوات الروسيه وسيطر على بلدات اضافيه
لكن المحور الاكثر سخونه دائما هو باخمت
المنطقه الشماليه من مقاطعه
روسيا ومن داخل ضخمه ناحيه اوكرانيا
بالفعل راوية تشهد المنطقه في شمال مقاطعه
ديناسك وهي مدينه
وما حولها اجلاء لجميع السكان الذين
يقطنون في البلدات والقرى المجاوره
للمدينه ذلك مع الدفع اعداد كبيره من
الجنود الروس كامدادات عسكريه بشريه
وبالاليات ايضا لتلك المنطقه لتعزيز
القوات التي تقاتل حول مدينه باخموت ايضا
من الناحيه الاخرى جانب الاوكراني اعلنت
السلطات الاوكرانيه عن اجلاء جميع السكان
من المدينه لا بد ان هناك يعني تحضير
لعمليه عسكريه كبيره اكبر من التي نشهدها
هذه الايام حول مدينه باقمت بالفعل تقدمت
قوات فاغنر من الناحيه الجنوبيه من مدينه
باقمت في عمق المدينه انطلاقا من مدينه
ايفانجرات كما ان قوات فاجنر ايضا ما زالت
تقاتل نعم مدينه بريخوفكا في المنطقه
الشماليه هي البوابه الشماليه لمدينه
باخمه وقتال شوارع
المعارك هناك بانها الاكثر شراسه ربما
بالنشرات اللاحقات تزودنا بتلك المعلومات
الاضافيه شكرا جزيلا لك من دنياتك
كشفت او كشف رئيس لجنه التحقيق الروسيه
الكسان عن جمع ادله تثبت تورط القياده
العسكريه والسياسيه لاوكرانيا في الاباده
الجماعيه لسكان دومباس ايضا استعداد
اللجنه لتقديم نتائج التحقيق وعرضها في
المحكمه من صور ووثائق وشهود تثبت تورط
النظام الاوكراني في ارتكاب جرائم ضد
الانسانيه على حد قوله
وقال الرئيس الاوكراني في مقابله مع صحيفه
كوريا ديلاسيرا الايطاليه ان الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون يهدر وقته
بالتفكير في اي نوع من الحوار مع روسيا
مشيرا الى انه حتى لو جرى نقاش فانه سيكون
عديم الفائده لان اوكرانيا توصلت الى
النتيجه انه لا يمكن تغيير الموقف الروسي
الحالم لاعاده بناء الامبراطوريه
السوفيتيه القديمه ياتي تصريح زيلينسكي
ردا على اقوال ماكرون الذي عبر فيها
لصحيفه لوجونال دودي عن رغبته في انه لابد
من حسم الصراع في اوكرانيا اما عبر
المفاوضات او هزيمه روسيا ولكن ليس بسحقها
على حد قوله تصريحات ماكرون لم تذهب هباء
فالمتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
ماريا زخرفه جهزت كالعاده ردها اللاذع
خاصه حول عبارته تلك القائله ان فرنسا
تريد ان تلحق الهزيمه بروسيا في اوكرانيا
لكنها لم في سحقها وانتقدته مستذكره
الماضي بالحاضر قائله انه بالنسبه لهذه
الكلمه لم تبدا فرنسا
بمكرومات نابليون بونابرت على مستوى
الدوله راقده في قلب باريس كما واتهمت
زخرفه تصريحات ماكرون وديبلا دبلوماسيته
بانها قيمه على الرياء وتابعت بشكل عام ان
مكرون بلا قيمه خاصه وانه ان اقوال فعليا
متضاربه على حد وصفها فيما يتعلق بالوضع
في اوكرانيا وحول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا
الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه الدكتور محمد
سيف الدين اهلا بك معنا دكتور محمد يعني
هذا يعني التبادل بالاتهامات تحديدا بين
روسيا وفرنسا الى اي مدى يعني يؤكد بان
هناك ربما قطيعه بالايام القادمه
لم يعد هنالك حوار خاصه وان مكروم حسب
زخرفه كان له دور كبير ببدايه هذه الحرب
بفتح قنوات للتواصل وانهاء هذه الحرب هل
انتهى الدور الفرنسي في هذه الحرب
نعم بدايه يعني طوال فتره هذه الحرب ومنذ
انطلاقتها كان الموقف الفرنسي مختلفا
ومتبينا عن بقيه القوى الرئيسه في التحالف
الغربي مكون كان دائما يحاول مد جسور
التواصل والابقاء على التواصل يعني طمعا
بتوليد حل سياسي او مقترح لتوليد حل سياسي
في الفترات الاولى من الحرب عندما تقدمت
الحرب ومرت الاشهر زاد التوتر وارتفع
وارتفعت المواجهه الى اقصى الى اقصى حد من
العنف وبالتالي زادت الضغوط ايضا
الامريكيه في قلب التحالف الغربي على
القوى على المانيا وعلى فرنسا واصبح
ماكرون في موقف اكثر حرجا بهذا الامر
بموازاه ذلك كانت يعني حماوه المعارك
وتقدم القوات الروسيه ويعني كل ما يتولد
من ذلك كان ايضا يضغط على الرئيس الفرنسي
للالتزام اكثر في التحالف الغربي اعتقد
الان ان الدوره الفرنسي نعم هو مهدد
العلاقات الروسيه الفرنسيه مهدده تصريحات
ماكرون بالمناسبه في مؤتمر ميونخ لم ترضي
طرفي اني لم ترضي اوكرانيا من جهه ولم
ترضي روسيا من جهه اخرى لان هذه التصريحات
ربما تكون الان هي الاكثر واقعيه بشكل
انها تريد الحفاظ على وحده الموقف
الاوروبي من جهه ولكن تريد ان تؤسس في
المستقبل لاستعاده العلاقات مع روسيا
ومعها استعاده المصالح مع روسيا يعني هناك
بالحديث عن نقطه تغيير النظام بروسيا
للمواقف هذه الايام نقطه تغيير النظام
بروسيا اثرتها زخرفه بانه روسيا نعم ولكن
يعني هل فعليا هذا ما يريده الغرب من وراء
استنزاف روسيا عسكريا وهل هذا ما اصلا
مقتنعه به روسيا وتتصرف على اثاثه انه
يريدون تغيير النظام في بلدنا
منذ الاسابيع الاولى للحرب وخصوصا في
الاشهر الاخيره كان هناك تصريحات غربيه
ليست فرنسيه لكنها في التحالف الغربي تشير
الى ضروره ان يكون هناك حكم اخر في روسيا
وان يتم يعني هناك تغير ديمقراطي كما
يسمونه في روسيا الموقف الفرنسي مختلف عن
ذلك والموقف الفرنسي كما اشرت هو اكثر
واقعيه لكن مكرون في تصريحه في ميونخ قال
ان اي تغيير سياسي في روسيا سوف يجلب الى
السلطه من هم اكثر تطرفا من مواقف بوتين
الحاليه وهو اشار الى باتروشيف واشار الى
رئيس رئيس منظمه باغنير بيجوجين وبالتالي
هو يتوقع بان اي تغيير في روسيا سيذهب
بالاتجاه المعاكس لما يتمناه الغرب وهو
بناء على ذلك يقول بان المفاوضات مع روسيا
واعاده اطلاق المسار السياسي مع روسيا هو
امر لا بد منه في وقت في وقت ما وهو اشار
ايضا في مقابل ذلك الى عدم جدول حوار في
هذه اللحظه الغرب وبما فيه فرنسا ينتظ
تقدما للقوات الاوكرانيه في الاسابيع
المقبله فيما لو كان ذلك ممكنا لاعاده وصل
المفاوضات كما يدعو اليها اليها مكرون لكن
الاجواء تشير الان ايضا يعني التوقيت مهم
جدا لان المواقف التي صدرت في قمه ميونخ
تتحسب لهجوم روسي واسع وهي تحاول التصعيد
في مواجهه هذا هذا الهجوم طمعا بان تحاول
الضغط على بوتين لعدم شن هجوم كبير جدا
وبالتالي هذا هذه المواقف عاليه السقف هذا
الهدف منها بشكل بشكل رئيسي بالاضافه الى
ذلك هناك تباينات كبيره جدا يعني بين
اعضاء التحالف الغربي ومنها ما اشار اليها
المستشار الالماني عن موضوع بان المانيا
طلب منها يعني المبادره وتقديم الدبابات
وتقديم المساعدات العسكريه بشكل كبير جدا
بينما القوى الاخرى لم تسهم بنفس القدر
ولم تسهم بالمستوى الذي اعلنت عنه في
السابق وبالتالي تبقى هذه الخلافات موجوده
لكن قدره الضبط الامريكيه للمواقف في هذا
التحالف ايضا هي حاضره وبالتالي فان
الاحداث الميدانيه هي التي ستغير هذا
الساتيكو الذي يعني يتراوح في الايام
الاخيره شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من باريس
الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه الدكتور محمد
سيف الدين
اذا خارجيه ايران الان تقول انها ترفض
اتهامات اسرائيل بان طهران هاجمت ناقله
نفطن في الخليج نتابع عن زياره وزير
الخارجيه الصيني
بعد جوله اوروبيه اعلن خلالها خطه صينيه
للسلام في اوكرانيا وتعليقا على التحذيرات
الامريكيه عن علاقتها مع روسيا قلت
الخارجيه الصينيه بان بيكين لا تسمحوا
لاحد بالضغط عليها ولا تقبل الاتهامات
الامريكيه ولم تحدد وزاره الخارجيه ما اذا
كان الوزير الصيني سيلتقي بالرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوت
نفعت منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه ما
تردد عن تخصيبها لليورانيوم بنسبه 84%
والقريبه من درجه نقاوه صنع الاسلحه
النوويه وقال المتحدث باسم منظمه الطاقه
الذريه الايرانيه ان بلاده لم تقم حتى
الان باي موحى ولا للتخصيب تخصيب
اليورانيوم بالنسبه تزيد عن 60% وكان
التقرير لوكاله بلومبرج اورد ان هذه هي
المره الثانيه هذا الشهر التي يكتشف فيها
من قبل مراقبين عن انشطه مشبوهه تتعلق
بتقسيم اليورانيوم في منشاه نوويه
الايرانيه
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل عشرات
القتلى في فيضانات وانهيارات ارضيه حصلت
في البرازيل كما نشاهد في هذه الصور
اهلا بكم من جديد نبدا الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو بوتيريش بالتجربه
الصاروخيه التي اجرتها كوريا الشماليه
نهايه الاسبوع داعيا الى الكف فورا عن
الاعمال الاستفزازيه ووفق المتحدثين
العام على ضروره امتثال الامم المتحده
الالتزاماتها الدوليه بموجب جميع قرارات
مجلس الامن ذات الصله واستئناف الحوار
المؤدي الى السلام المستدامي واخلاء شبه
الجزيره الكوريه من الاسلحه النوويه
جانبه قال كبير امناء مجلس الوزراء
الياباني هيروكازو ماتسونو اناطوكيو بشده
التجربه الصاروخيه الاخيره لكوريا
الشماليه مؤكدا على ان بيوم بيانغ تنتهك
قرارات مجلس الامن وتهدد سلامه وامناء
اليابان والمنطقه
اطلقت كوريا الشماليه اليوم قرابه الساعه
السابعه صباحا صاروخين باليسيين قصي المدى
باتجاه الشرق بالقرب من الساحل الغربي
لكوريا الشماليه اطلاق الصاروخين ينتهك
ايضا قرارات مجلس الامن ذات الصله وقدمت
اليابان احتجاجا شديدا على كوريا الشماليه
وادانا ذلك بشده سلسله الاجراءات التي
تتخذها كوريا الشماليه تهدد سلامه وامن
اليابان والمنطقه والمجتمع الدولي وهي غير
مقبوله على الاطلاق
اذا السعوديه اتوقعوا مشاريع لصالح
متضررين الزلزال بتركيا وسوريا باكثر من
1883 مليون ريال سعودي افاد مراسل العربيه
بوقوع اشتباكات عنيفه بين حرس الحدود
الباكستاني وقوات طالبان في معبر طوررخم
بباكستان وعلى اثر الاشتباكات تم اغلاق
المعبر الذي يربط بين باكستان وافغانستان
فيما طلب من السكان اللجوء الى اماكن امنه
في ظل استمرار المعارك بين الجانبين
باستخدام الاسلحه الخفيفه والثقيله
وينضم الينا من كابول عبد الله نادر مراسل
العربيه اهلا بك عبد الله يعني هل عرف
السبب الحقيقي من وراء هذه الاشتباكات
وايضا ماذا عن السكان والى اين لجاوا
لحد الان ليست هناك اسباب واضحه لبدء هذه
الاشتباكات التي بدات صباح اليومي
واستخدمت فيه الاسلحه الثقيله والخفيفه
ونطلب من المواطنين والمسافرين الموجودين
هناك المغادره من هذه المنطقه في اسرع وقت
ممكن كما طلبت السلطات الافغانيه من
المسافرين الافغان عدم التوجه الى معبر
تورخم وبشكل عام الى ممر خيبر كانت حكومه
طالبان قد اغلقت قد اغلقت
الليله منذ الليله الماضيه امام الركابي
والمركبات التجاريه بشكل عام وقال مفوض او
مسؤول من الجانب الافغاني ان الجانب
الباكستاني لم يفي بالتزاماته التي
قطعها
لهذا المعبر وبالتالي الان توقفت
الاشتباكات ولكن العلاقات السياسيه
والامنيه متوتره بين الجانبين
الى حد كبير حيث
الجانب الافغاني غاضب على امور كثيره منها
تصريحات ورئيس الوزراء الباكستاني بلون
بوترداري في مؤتمر مونيخ بانه صرح بان
افغانسان ستصبح مره اخرى بوتقطه الارهاب
الدولي وهذه الوزاره الخارجيه الافغانيه
اصدرت بيانا نددت فيه بهذه بهذه التصريحات
وقال ان هذه التصريحات
ليست مناسبه ان تطرح في المؤتمرات الدوليه
بشكل عام هناك كذلك اتهامات متبادله بين
الجانبين
الجانب الباكستاني يتهم الجانب الافغاني
بوائه
طالبان باكستان
شكرا جزيلا لك اذا منك ابو عبد الله نادر
مراسل العربيه
انطلقت قبل ساعات اعمال النسخه الثالثه من
منتظر رياض الدولي الانسانيه بمشاركه عدد
من القاده والمانحيين والعاملين والخبراء
في مجال العمل الانساني وكيل الامين العام
للامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه اكد خلال
المنتدى ان النظام العالمي يواجه تحديات
وبحاجه الى تعاون دولي من جهته قال
المفاوض السامي لشؤون اللاجئين فيليبو
غراندي ان تمويل المرن هو اهم عامل للتخطي
الازمات الحاليه في مجال الاغاثات وتستمر
اعمال المنتدى لمده يومين في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض
ومن هنا من الرياض انضم الينا مراسل
العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي اهلا بك عبد
المحسن اهم ما خرج به اليوم الاول من
منتدى الرياض الانساني
نعم راويه بالفعل قبل ساعات بدات المؤتمر
بجلسه رفيعه المستوى شارك فيها رؤساء
منظمات دوليه انسانيه تابعه للامم المتحده
بالاضافه الى مركز الملك سلمان بالاضافه
الى الوزير عادل الجبير
السعودي الذي تحدث خلال هذه الجلسه عن عدد
من
المحاور المختصه بالعمل الانساني وقال بان
السعوديه قدمت خلال 20 21 اكثر من سبعه
مليارات دولار كمساعدات ومنح لهذه
المنظمات الانسانيه التي تشارك بشكل كبير
جدا
بمستوى رفيع في هذا المؤتمر الذي انطلق
قبل ساعات وايضا قبل اقل من نصف ساعه بدات
جلسه الافتتاح لهذا المؤتمر بحضور وزير
الخارجيه السعودي فيصل بن فرحان بالاضافه
الى مارتن جريفيت وكيل الامير العام لمنظم
للامم المتحده لشؤون الانسانيه بال الى
كافه المنظمات الامميه المشاركه في هذه
المنتدى ومنها منظمه صليب او صليب الاحمر
وكذلك الهجره منظمه الهجره الدوليه وعدد
من المنظمات التي تشارك في هذا المنتدى
لطرح عدد من المواضيع ربما ابرز ما تم
طرحه خلال الجلستين الاولى هو عمليه
التمويل ونقص التمويل لهذه المنظمات
والعمل الانساني بشكل كبير جدا والوصول
الى اكبر عدد ممكن من المحتاجين حول
العالم ذكر رقم بان 300 اكثر من 330 مليون
انسان حول العالم يحتاجون لمساعدات
بالاضافه الى ان
المساعدات
الحاليه او المنح المقدمه والمساهمات
الماليه لا تغطي الا ما يقارب 70% من
الاحتياج المالي وبالتالي عمليات المنح
والمطالبه
بالمساعدات بالاضافه عبد المحسن عدد الدول
المساهمه او عشره دول
سنتابع غدا فعاليات اليوم الثاني من هذا
المؤتمر شكرا جزيلا لك عبد المحسن الحربي
اهلا بكم من جديد تسببت الفيضانات
وانهيارات التربه الناجمه عن الامطار
الغزيره بمقتل 36 شخصا على الاقل في ولايه
بحسب السلطات البرازيليه
نهايه النشره تذكير بابرز العناوين
تركيا تحذروا من انهيار مباني جراء الهزات
الارتداديه ويونسف تعلن تعرض اكثر من سبعه
ملايين طفل للخطر
قصف اوكرانيون مكثف على دنيتك وضواحي
بخموت وروسيا تتهم بارتكاب اباده جماعيه
في
بعد استفزازات كوريا الشماليه بالتجارب
الصاروخيه الباليستيه الامم المتحده تحذر
واليابان
اغلاق معبر طور خم الحدودي مع افغانستان
بعد اشتباكات عنيفه بين طرفين
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]